so i hope you can all see my
presentation
and as it has been already said this
will be a talk to
convince you that x-ray is not just
pandas in multiple dimensions but a lot
more
i'm currently piled higher and deeper in
at the institute of plasma physics of
the
academy of sciences which hopefully
explains why my relationship to data is
that it is wrong
i'm not a core x-ray developer but
i'm a very active user and i develop
develop some of
my own extensions and extensions that
other people use so
this talk will be given mostly from a
perspective of a
very active user
i'll start by explaining why you might
want to consider
looking at yet another library when we
already have numpy and pandas
then i'll give you a brief overview of
at least the basics of the x-ray api
i'll start with a brief technical
structural review and then give you some
basic usage examples
and then i'll show some more advanced
usage
for example how you can wrap some nice
methods from scipy and then one of my
favorite
uh i would say perhaps um
abuses of the whole api to uh
essentially write paralyzed for loops
uh with desk and broadcasting magic
so we all love numpy but quite often we
find ourselves in this
situation where we have some dependent
variable here y
and we would want to select y for which
x is between two and three one common
workaround that
is that i've seen used many times and
i've used it in the past myself is that
you create a boolean mask
that works but it's not exactly
efficient
now these days there it's a no-brainer
you just use pandas and it works very
well
it's very efficient and quite concise
but pandas is mostly oriented at 1d
you could say that data frames are 2d
that is
kind of true but the most of the api is
still
aimed at uh working with data frames as
if they were dictionaries of series
so it's not exactly general when you
want to work with more than one
dimension
you can actually get away with working
with something like a multi-dimensional
array if you flatten all the dimensions
into one multi-index
which actually is pretty useful when
your data is sparse in the multiple
dimensions
but it's not exactly convenient and
super easy to use
and this is where x-ray comes in because
it generalizes this
pandas indexing machinery into
multiplied dimensions
but there's more uh one other thing that
i've
often encountered is that i've wished
that numpy had name dimensions
and let's first think about what we
actually mean by dimensions
when we work with numpy we're actually
working with something we might call
algebraic dimensions that means rows
columns
and depths but these may or may not
correspond to some physical dimensions
of let's say spatial or temporal
meaning so let's say i have some tensor
of
shape 573 could correspond to time and
some spatial dimensions
and let's say i then perform some
calculations and i move around
the axis for some reason so i'm
transposing it then i'm swapping axes
who knows what it is now can you guess
what the shape is
it's not that easy and now let's say i
want to perform the mean
over the x-axis and now where is it
it's not that easy to guess actually i'm
going to think well i transpose it so i
reverse this order
now i have so i swap the second and
third
so which one is it well the true correct
answer is that it is the second one
you see that we removed uh we removed
the dimension with size seven which was
x
so that is something uh that is quite
inconvenient
and what x-ray does is that it assigns
names to dimensions so instead of
using axis equals something you can
specify
the dimension to your plot some function
be applied over
directly by a name of course that works
in wrapped functions and methods and
we'll talk about those later
so you don't need to remember any
explicit dimension ordering
and another benefit is that if some
dimension is missing
then if you want to apply let's say a
mean over that dimension then you'll
get a failure it's an explicit failure
whereas if you are
using let's say mean with axis minus one
or or
zero or something like that then that
might actually work
but it suddenly might pack a surprise
for later when
uh down the line you might find out oh
my array is suddenly
uh has a completely different shape than
i expected
and in pandas a data frame has only
algebraic
dimensions they call it the index and
columns dimensions
with a multi-index you kind of do have
explicit
dimension ordering because you can have
dimension kind
like dimension level names in the multi
index
but then you have to track their order
and and so on
and yet another thing that i love and uh
probably makes numpy and all the other
libraries derive from it
so popular and powerful here i'm talking
for example
about tensorflow or pi torch or whatever
is that there's this thing called numpy
broadcasting
which at least in terms of computation
means that you can
perform implicit and with not by at the
sea level
very fast for loops in arithmetic
operations and they and they vectorize
automatically well i have kind of
automatically
and when you apply uh functions which
support such
apis mostly universal functions they
also their arguments also vectorize
but it's not exactly so easy and so
readable uh
in practice so consider that um
i have this 1d array of time values
and it does have those to make it
simpler i give it the same size that
uh as the time dimension had in the
previous
race and now i just want to multiply it
with
uh with the previous result but that
fails spectacularly
because uh numpy broadcasting has
some rules and for instance uh the
dimension
the dimensions have to align from from
the backwards
in the shape and so this doesn't
actually work so
one solution is to uh reshape this so
you say
well okay i understand that i'll have to
eat my pie and
reshape it like so and then it works
now tell me would you just remember
which way you have to reshape it it's
not that
easy and so this is again where x-ray
comes to the help
it comes to the rescue because it
handles all this broadcasting
uh according to dimension names which it
knows about so
it checks whether the dimension sizes
match
and possibly it can align them by
associated coordinates if they don't
match completely and it handles all this
reshaping and transposing
before arithmetic operations and it also
handles
all of the broadcasting within you funds
or you can use it for
other functions via the apply you func
helper api which we'll
which i'll briefly show later
and just to uh be fair with with pandas
with a multi-index
flat uh and dimensional uh data frame
you kind of still get the same thing
because you're aligning just a 1d thing
so there's an alignment actually
and just to point out that this really
is a general problem
uh pytorch since version 1.3
uh has this thing called named tensors
which
have a similar use case that they track
the dimensions according to their names
so enter x-ray
let me say that this is actually a pure
python
library but it does depend on some
compiled
dependencies some of them which are
optional of course it depends on numpy
and
mostly on pandas and it's heavily
inspired by the netcdf file format so it
so it uh makes a lot of use of that if
you want to store
data but there are but it's not
mandatory
and it's one it's a project with one of
the best
documentation websites i've ever seen
it's very well structured and has many
examples so it's whenever you
actually want to learn something how to
do something with xray
you almost always find it there and just
to give a brief historical context
which will hopefully uh shine a bit of
light why some things work they do
this is actually an evolution of some
internal tool they've developed at some
climate car corporation group so it is
mainly
it has been mainly uh used and developed
by people working with
climate scientists climate science or
geoscience
originally they released it as x-ray and
they quickly realized that this is not
exactly a good name
because of course it clashes with many
packages used by other people
and a few years ago it also became part
of the non-focus group
i'll first start with the technical
overview uh
now there's this thing called a variable
object
it's actually an internal part of the
api but it's
the core building block so you don't
actually need to use it and you don't
really need to
know much about it in day-to-day usage
of x-ray but i believe it's very useful
to
uh know about it in order to appreciate
what x-ray actually does
so this object wraps a numpy array or at
least
not a numpy like array it actually has
to be something called a duck array so
it just has to
fulfill some of some
behavior that a numpy ray would have and
you wrap that
with some dimensions metadata
and possibly some other optional
metadata so it's not
an nd array subclass uh but it has many
sort of mixing properties so it has all
these various
attributes and methods that you might
expect from an ndra like
class and that's a very important point
uh to make
that x-ray is built on the idea of
composition over inheritance so they
don't actually make subclasses of
ndraise they just
put together many mixing classes and
that's how they add in various
properties
and it's heavily inspired by this
necesity of file format that stands for
network common data format
since version for that essentially means
it's the hierarchical data format
plus some geoscience data conventions
so uh typically you import x-ray as xr
as you might do with numpy s np
[Music]
and now we just wrap some random uh
numpy array and all we do is that we
specify
the names that correspond to these
algebraic dimensions these are just
names they could be anything
just strings and we can also specify
some arbitrary
metadata which is useful to have
especially when you're working with
simulation data
possibly some encoding metadata when
you're working with some special input
output back-ends
but it's not mandatory
and this is result you see that they
already have their own html
representation and jupiter notebook
so you see that it essentially just
wraps this numpy array
but it has this metadata which tells us
the names and order of the dimensions
and all of the further api i will cover
in a moment
mainly data array and data set these are
containers which are essentially
built on top of mappings uh which
point from some name of a variable to a
variable
like object when i'm talking about i'll
be talking
about mappings for those of you who
don't really know or aren't familiar
with that term in python
that essentially just means i'm talking
about objects which behave like
dictionaries
so the data array container is
essentially mostly like a variable but
it's got
associated coordinates so it wraps one
main array
and we can possibly give it some
specific name and
the new thing is that we add uh chords
coordinates attribute which is a mapping
from a coordinate
name to some associated coordinate or
label data array
so this is how we would create a data
array again we've got some random some
data a numpy data
we give it we have to tell
what the what are the names of these
algebraic dimensions we can we
can give it a name and then we specify
a dictionary or a mapping of these
coordinate arrays you see that i'm
i don't have to be actually data raised
when i'm constructing it it wraps it
automatically
typically you'll want to provide
coordinate
labels which correspond to some
dimensions but it's not mandatory
and here we have some extra data so this
is the result
looks similar as before but now we got
this coordinates
mapping here see that this html
representation has nice
collapsible uh features and so on
and what happens when we add these
coordinates
which whose name correspond to
some dimension in this data array and if
it's 1d
then it creates a pandas index
for that dimension
so here we see that uh this t
uh coordinate indeed is present
and because we also specify the x
coordinate we have an index presence
which we can then use for indexing and
slicing and so on
so just to note this
representation in jupiter notebook
it's html by by default since a recent
version
and uh you might have noticed that some
some of these dimensions are bold and
some aren't that's because
a bold dimension tells you that it does
have an
index associated so you can use it for
slicing label based slicing
if it doesn't have a bold name then it
probably doesn't
have it available and here i added
an extra coordinate which isn't
associated with any dimension and you
see that it
is present but it's not bold
when you see it in text form
you don't have bold in text form so
instead
an asterisk asterisk symbol is used
in front of the coordinate name in the
coordinates mapping and
those dimensions with our currents are
explicitly listed
so at this point uh i think it's useful
to point out
that whereas in pandas the core building
block of
everything is an index and its presence
is
essentially mandatory even if you don't
supply an index you get sort of a
placeholder
into integer index in x-ray
the real core building block are the
dimensions
which are encoded in a variable like
object
and the index is actually optional
so that's a big difference and now the
data set
is essentially just a container uh
which is essentially just a mapping of
data race so it's similar to how a data
frame
is essentially a mapping of series in
pandas
and the main point is that it actually
contains just one chord's mapping which
is a union
of all the contained uh variables
of of the coordinates of all the other
contained variables
so we might define a data set like so
that we will
this is uh these will be the data
variables
we'll we'll give them some dimension
we'll see what the dimension names are
and supply the data and we might have a
different one here with only some
dimensions and
perhaps some different data i'm just
using part of the data
and we'll supply coordinates which are
shared by all of the data variables
and here's the output so it's a data set
we're told that it has these dimensions
it's got these coordinates and these
data variables
so data variables is a mapping
again similar to chords from name to
data array
and this is the mapping that is actually
used whenever you apply
uh any mapping like api to the actual
data set
so the dataset is a mapping itself it
does support its api so you can
use item getting or assignment you can
use the keys method items method
it's right over it as of this version it
operates on this map
only on this mapping previously it
operated on the variables mapping
which was a union of both chords and
data variables which would return
something different
so uh when it's safer to explicitly say
over which mapping you want to use
let's say iterate or something like that
if you ever encounter that and you might
be wondering so what's the actual
difference between these
this coordinates mapping and the and
this data virus mapping
to some extent it's mostly semantic uh
this coordinates mapping is intended
mostly for
fixed or independent quantities and the
data vars
are intended for measured or dependent
quantities
it's also uh inspired by the net cdf
file format where there is this
distinction and usually it's quite a
reasonable distinction
of course there's a big difference in
its usage for an indexing only those
variables in quartz can be used for
indexing if they're 1d
and a lot of various helpers or other
libraries might
assume that this is true for for
instance a plot
accessory which we'll cover later we'll
take
x or values or labels from
this mapping and the y from this mapping
or in
the case of 2d the xy from this one and
the color
let's say from this mapping so that's
the main difference
so for this tutorial uh i'll load
one of the tutorial data sets from
private from by x-ray
it's air temperature data above the us
in some two years i'm not a climate
scientist
so here's a big flat big fat disclaimer
all of this
is just for illustration and don't make
any
conclusions from whatever i do with the
data and hopefully i won't be doing
anything
too stupid so that's that
so let's load it if you run it on your
own
later on this just downloads and caches
some 17 megabyte
led with file and wraps it and opens it
with the xr open data set function
so here we have another data set it's a
bit larger than we had last time so
finally something to work with
and one thing you might notice is that
we only see three dots here
for the data so we look at the data and
there is no data it just tells us that
it has a lot of values of this data type
why is that well that's because
open data set and there's also a similar
method called open data array
actually don't load all of the data into
memory
at the beginning they only load
coordinates into memory and of course
they inspected
the file and find out what variables are
available but that means that
selecting and sizing still works by even
with index
and the data variables are loaded only
when their actual values are
truly accessed that means when you try
to calculate something or you try to
slice them
or you can do it explicitly with the
load method
there's also a companion method called
load dataset
which just follows open data set with
load so it will load all data into
memory but that's typically not what you
want to do
although for some other operations you
might so that's it just gives you some
control so if we then access this data
array
this air temperature data array and we
pluck it out of the data set then we see
it tells us it's just got these
many values of this data type but now if
we try to slice it
or well we are actually slicing here
because as you might have noticed
this is actually a date time array so it
works in a similar way as in pandas if
you
supply just part of the date you'll
actually create a slice over some time
period
then it actually loads actual data and
you see that it actually loads
uh four time slices because this doesn't
specify the hour
one thing that we love in pandas is that
you have these attribute
access aliases and it works in a similar
fashion in x-ray as well
so if you access ds dot
some name then it first tries to access
it by
item name which then for dataset means
it first tries the date of ours and
it's not there tries the coordinates and
if it's not there then it
tries if it might be an attribute name
so all of this all of these things will
return pretty much the same thing but
there's a catch
these two things don't they attribute
access and item access may not
return the identical object because
these
data arrays which are returned are
created on demand
so these objects will not be identical
but they will be considered equal in
terms of dimensions and content
so you see that you can access whatever
you want in a very straightforward way
and
of course you have to make sure that
you're not aliasing some other methods
with for data array it looks in a
similar way just just uh
there's the difference that it doesn't
have data bars because it's itself it
has just one data variable
uh but surprisingly you can actually
access
a coordinates
variable from a data array by item
method like the getitem method
but that's sort of just a quirk
[Music]
okay of course
part of why we like attribute access is
because
we like tab competition and
x-ray does have some mixing classes
which implement this helper method
which is recognized by jupiter and other
uh
and possibly some other uh composition
libraries
and when i if you use
attribute style access then if i start
writing a and i press tab
then you'll see that i get the error
variable
uh suggested but i also get a lot of
these various methods
which i might or might not want to find
so in that case uh
the item style access is sometimes a bit
more
convenient because it will
obviously find only those variables
which are actually
members of the data set although it also
find some jupiter
a mess i'm not sure if that's my bug or
just bug in my setup or if it's just a
jupiter issue
on the other hand uh the attribute style
access does have better
change composition of course that
depends on how your
tab composition library works for
example if i type air and i type
error all then that works whereas this
probably
won't work it actually works sometimes
but it's a bit slower because it has to
obtain the object and so on
so now let's get into more uh you sort
of use
cases so when you have a data array it
does kind of feel like a numpy like
array
and that also is true for a variable
object
the underlying data are actually
properties and you can either use the
data or
values properties the data is whatever
is truly contained by this
object it might be an nd array or it
could be a laser lazy data wrapper or a
desk array or a sparse array
but when you use the values property you
always get an nd array
it's something it kind of calls numpy as
ray on data
so when you want to apply a function to
uh some data it's usually safer to use
this
so if we have some data rate which is
wrapping an nd array then these things
will probably be the same
but in this case they aren't because
it's not not all of it is actually
loaded into memory
and it does have all the various
anterior like attributes like
endem shape size and bytes d type
whatever
and there's two extra which are
important that's the
dimension name dimension names and order
and also a mapping from their names to
the sizes of each dimension
so it's kind of a better uh better form
of shape
this is probably will be ordered the
same way as dims in
python 3 but it's not exactly guaranteed
okay so
now finally we get to how we index and
select
data when we do know the order of
dimensions
so of course it still works like a
normal array so you can use
integer positional indexing and you can
also use label-based indexing as you
would do in pandas
and of course as with pandas because we
are using pandas indices
label-based slicing is and inclusive so
here i'm indexing by integers so
hopefully at this point i know that this
is time this is
probably uh i think latitude and
longitude
if i use this then it's prep it's a bit
more understandable i mean this is some
time that i want this is some uh
some latitude range and this is some
long into longitude
so it also works
you might wonder whether uh this will
return a copy or
view a general rule is that
a copy will be returned to view
something like fancy indexing which
means that
whatever you're trying to get is not
representable by
integers or slices otherwise it should
be a view
that also has implications for
assignment
now if we don't want to deal with
trying to remember where our dimensions
are and what is their order
then we could specify the
names to to the values we're trying to
index
by actually giving a dictionary to the
get item operator and it also works for
the
location accessor and this can also be
used for assignment
but it's not exactly convenient so
that's why there are methods called isil
and cell which are for integer
and label-based slicing and selecting
respectively
but obviously because these are method
calls they can be used for assignment on
on the left side of a equal sign
[Music]
hopefully in the future if this python
enhancement proposal gets through
we'll be able to write something like
this where you would
specify the dimension which would
essentially be a short form for this
here
until then if we use calls like this we
unfortunately have to specify a slice
with a true slice object because this
will not be a valid
syntax with a column anymore but on the
internet
at least it works also for data sets and
there's also a thing called vectorize
indexing
uh which enables very interesting tricks
but i won't cover that
you can look into documentation if
you're interested and so
the equivalent of specifying something
like this with the location accessor
based on positions would be uh
done like this with name dimensions and
you see that i don't really have to
think about what is the order of the
dimensions and in my opinion it's a lot
more readable and that's why i actually
use it
whenever i can unless i'm very very lazy
or if it's only 1d and then
look accessory is unambiguous
of course we also have nearest neighbor
look up so the cell method has an
optional
method where you can say where you want
the nearest one or the
the forward fill or the backfill closet
value
you could also specify a tolerance so
that you don't get too far matches and
you get a cure if it's too far
so even though i'm specifying i want a
latitude of 75.5 degrees
and there's only 75 degrees available i
get the one that is pretty close
there's a similar plot
accessories you would find with panda's
data frames there's this
sort of magic plot accessory you can
even call it
and it calls the appropriate method
based on what's the dimensionality of
the
data array you're trying to pass so
if i do this then since error is 3d that
means it's more than 2d
it can't really plot it in any obvious
way so it's going to just give me a
histogram of all the values
and you see that it actually somehow
found the names
of the units and the description of the
signal that's because if
the description of the unit's attributes
are available for a data array or a
coordinate
data array it will use them for the
labels
and if i select just some time slice and
that will be 2d
then it will automatically plot it with
a p color mesh
wrapper and again you see that it found
all the various names of the
axes and so on and nicely labeled in the
time
so we could we can then of course modify
this plot with
typical map calls although you have to
remember that you should
modify the plot after you do the x-ray
calls because they
modify the titles themselves so
otherwise they might override whatever
you change
there's some more advanced features for
example if you
[Music]
you can use faceting with
even 3d arrays and
if you want to be sure that the x-axis
corresponds to longitude
then you just say so and it handles all
of the orienting and
on its own so you see that i took
four time slices and i said that i want
them uh
that i want the time dimension wrapped
in columns
with fast with a faster grid this is
similar to
what you might know for no no from c
board
another useful thing is that i could
plot a 2d array as a group of 1d lines
so here i
select uh this is just will be just a 2d
array and then i say plot it as a line i
can use
matplotlib pi plot style formatting
format strings and i just say that on
the x axis i want the time dimension
with some alpha value and some sizing of
the figure
and it automatically adds this legend
and labels the various
time traces
when you want to work with in a more
interactive way with uh
plotting i personally prefer the hp plot
accessor which is provided by the hp
plot
project which in turn wraps all of use
which in turn
wrap bokeh so that gives you a much
nicer interface
because now you get a nice tool tip and
you can zoom in
as you might know from bokeh and so on
and you get also a nice slider
so it's very convenient on the other
hand it's not so easy to use when you
want to save
an actual figure
as i've already said before most numpy
like methods
which would need to specify an axis then
you can usually if you use
data array method then you can specify a
dim
name instead you can still specify an
axis number if you want to
by default almost all of these methods
skip
not a number values you can control that
by a skip an a
argument as you might do in pandas and
the attributes
that you might have assigned are quite
often dropped by these methods because
in theory if you do some transformation
of a matrix it's a different matrix so
you shouldn't keep
keeping the attributes anymore
so here you see that i just specify give
me the mean over the longitude
dimension and that's it here i'm
actually assigning the result back into
the data set so you can use a data set
as sort of a data name space
so that you keep all your data on the
same coordinates so it's
pretty convenient when if you want to
then later slice
all the data variables at once
and you see that i that we reduced the
longitude dimension away
and here we can also see that the this
variable appeared here since we assigned
it
there now
if you want to wrap some other numpy
methods most numpy functions especially
you funds which do respect
the array interface they will correctly
wrap the result in a data array
object again and add some metadata but
if you don't uh encounter if you
encounter a function that doesn't
actually do that then you might have to
use the apply you func function which
i'll
show later and some sometimes you might
get away with just
getting the axis number from this helper
method
but then it doesn't wrap it if you just
specify if you just give it the raw
numpy data so whenever possible try to
use this
helper function which is much more
general and much
more robust of course arithmetic
operations which are essentially
functions as well
they as i said they handle reshaping and
aligning
to an inner join of coordinates
by default to use it does an inner join
of coordinates you can configure that by
the
set options method so here if i
calculate the squared function of the
means
and then i select just three latitudes
then if i subtract that
this array which is now which is only
three latitudes now
from the full array then you see that it
has only three latitude
uh just three latitude
parts or coordinates
and it handles all the reshaping and
aligning
because of course rt doesn't doesn't has
as many more latitude
labels and positions so it handles all
of that automatically and i don't even
have to think
what is the dime what is the order of
these dimensions
it's just all done automatically there's
a big fat warning
if i now try to assign this sort of
smaller array to this whole data set
then it will it will actually
align it to the outer join of all
coordinates of members
so if i run this you'll see that
suddenly there's a lot of nand values
because it tries to
align it with the other ones so that's
something to remember especially when
you have very sparse variables that if
you assign if you
sort of merge them into a dataset with
some variables which may larger smaller
or at
or positioned at different coordinates
you might get a lot of nand values and
that might
occupy a lot of memory so that's
something to remember of course this is
a mapping so we can easily fix it like
this
and now let's get to the wrapping uh
whenever you want to wrap a u-func
like function or even a generalized
u-func function that's a
you find that engineer that can return
more results
then it's best to use this apply you
func
uh helper what this does is that it
prepares the data within
any data x-ray container you pass
including a data set
because it wraps all over all the
possible uh
data arrays and it prepares
uh the nd arrays from from these
variables or perhaps
desk chunks and it moves something
called
core dimensions to be last so it
transposes
the dimensions so that the dimensions
that you select as core
are glass and they are not broadcast and
it handles all the reshaping and lining
of the other
uh of the or other dimensions and the
broadcasting
and then it applies uh this function to
any rays or possibly chunks
and it's expected to apply only on core
dimensions
uh in a sort of an axis equals minus one
fashion
or perhaps to all dimensions at once if
it's not a function
that is vectorized by its on its own
like a typical you function you can
it will wrap it by non-p vectorize if
you tell it to
it can even paralyze over das chunks if
you give it a desk array
and it's great if you combine it with a
number geo-vectorized
jitted function and then it wraps the
results
possible many several results in x-ray
containers again
so for instance if i want to apply the
so-well filter from
scipy and the image library then i just
apply this function let's say i can
apply it to the whole data set
and all i need to say is that i want it
to be applied along the latitude
dimension so i'll say latitude dimension
is the core dimension
here it's actually little the syntax is
a little strange because you
have to give a list of lists of core
dimensions for each of the inputs
so since i'm giving only one input it's
actually a list of
just one list and then on the result
because we didn't reduce the dimension
it's still there
then it's still that core dimension is
still present so we have to specify that
as well so i can wrap it correctly
and then we just have to specify uh
that the keyword arguments passed to
this function
or method or whatever uh does get that
it should apply along the last dimension
the last axis since that will since the
core dimension will be moved there
many functions have this as a default
but if you're not sure then you should
check the documentation
so here you see that i'm applying the
whole it to the whole data set so i'll
get a new data set
and then if i just get the error
variable from that data set
and plot it then you see that indeed was
applied
so there are many libraries that have
used
this to make some functionality from
other libraries available
uh i've contributed uh and some of my
colleagues to
for instance the xr scipy library which
provides some common sci-fi wrappers for
spectral analysis filtering
integration and so on it's got some
rudimentary documentation although it's
in
kind of sort of a alpha stage so here
for instance
i just import xr scipy
and i can apply the i can import the
signal
uh sub package which contains the
seventh goal a
filter for those who of you don't know
what a subscribe filter is
it essentially runs along data and
it gives you the same result as if you
sequentially fitted polynomials of a
given order
and gives you either the value at the
point at the center of that fit or
perhaps a derivative
of that polynomial at that point so here
i just apply
a goalie filter and i just specify
language dimension
and i can even say that the width of the
window
will be specified in the units of that
dimension so i'm here
giving a window over 30 longitudes and
you see it
essentially took the derivative through
a second order
polynomial another useful library that
we've
developed with some of our colleagues is
one that wraps uh sci-fi stats and also
arch
which we use for bootstrapping probably
will merge it in the future into extra
cipher at least
the sci-fi stats part and it's even got
a nifty feature
uh where you can have sort of virtual
sample counts by a das
tree and then you apply operations to
these virtual samples and you
sample these uh you actually create real
samples only at the end
uh when you have a true a real desk
tree ready that's even more alpha stage
but anyways it's quite usable so if we
import
uh its stats then if we let's say have
an array of
means and and standard deviations here
we
have just one a zero d just a just a
scalar value
then we can apply uh applied to some
stats methods for example to create
random values
and it handles all of the broadcasting
with sample sizes and so on
automatically through the
apply you fund helper and especially if
you try to do it on your own it's you
might know that it's not that easy with
stats because it's got this strange
convention
and this creates a data array which has
a sample dimension along which you could
then perform some averaging or whatever
you want to do
so for instance you might apply some
non-linear operations
and then you might average over the
sample dimension
and again you get some result
and finally we're getting to the last
part uh das
chunking for those of you who don't know
what desk is
it essentially splits uh an array into
memory chunks and then
any operations that are supported are
applied
to each chunk in a parallel either
let's say through threads or multi in a
multi-processing way or perhaps in a
cluster and xray
exposes the das interface so you can
easily
create a desk you can easily turn a desk
array
sorry you can easily turn a data array
into
with just an nd array into something
that has a dash array underneath in its
data attribute simply by calling the
chunk
method which just expects a mapping from
dimensioning
into how how large you want the chunk
size to be in that dimension
and most of the methods and operations
that you might apply to a simple data
array will
work most of them and they will be
simply added to das
tree and then once you want to evaluate
the dash tree just call the compute
method
so to give you an example here i'm
importing the progress barges to
later on show you that something some
things are might be a bit slower
so let's say i have this uh error
temperature array and i chunk it in the
time dimension into
uh blocks that are that have 50
elements in time dimension
and it even shows us this nice html
representation of the dash
array so you see that even though it has
something like
16 megabytes then each chunk has only
several hundred kilobytes now because
it's
split into these chunks and any
operations that we might apply
will uh be performed in parallel
on each chunk and then added together so
for instance if we apply the mean over
time then it will
copy the mean over each of these chunks
this actually isn't a very
very efficient example to perform a mean
over chunk dimension but
it doesn't matter and then if you call
the compute function it will actually
actually then will it calculate the
result so in this case it was very fast
because obviously this is a very simple
operation but now
let's get to uh the cherry on top
and that is that if you combine
broadcasting with desk
you can get very cheap parallelized out
of memory for loops
for instance you typically might have
the problem that you want to
calculate for each time the percentage
of times
that the temperature was warmer at that
given time so that would mean that you
would have to run
a four cycle uh if you want that to fit
into memory because
that is sort of a n by n problem
and then for each time you would you
would calculate this and store it and
then
concatenate it into a new array and so
on but uh
sort of solution for lazy people like me
is that you create
uh sort of a copy or letter the view of
the array
and you give it a different dimension
called let's say time two and then you
broadcast it a lot
against the original array
but you have to remember to chunk it
otherwise your memory usage will explode
and because of the broadcasting you'll
get this uh
you'll get this outer product so let's
see what happens if i
if i rename the time dimension to time
two it will i go i will get a new data
array
[Music]
uh which is just a view of the in this
one but it has a different dimension
and now if i apply this operation i just
ask well this remember this one is the
one with the chunks this already has
chunked
and if i say well where is this value
larger than this value element wise then
this will actually create
a chunked uh data array which you see
that
if i really did it uh in true memory
space it would have something over 11
gigabytes
but because i chunked it then each chunk
has only
around 200 megabytes so it it's still
each
if each operation if uh
any operations are computed only on each
chunk it will still fit into my memory
and that will make sure that
i don't over commit my memory so here
then i just calculate the mean
over this time two dimension and compute
it
so now this will take a bit more longer
and we can see that my threads
are very active though my memory isn't
that usage isn't that bad so that seems
to be done
and here we have a result so you see i
didn't have to write one four cycle
i just used the beauty of broadcasting
and outer products
and because we use dimensional metadata
i didn't even have to think
whether there's an outer product or
anything like that it just happens
automatically
i didn't cover many other things but i
just can't take
the whole night of your time
but most of the other things that i
didn't cover are quite similar with
pandas
or are very domain specific so all i can
say just go check out the docs they are
really great
just to give you an idea uh there's
all of the documentation has many
examples
and is very well written most of this
code that you can directly copy paste
and play around with it
and
now to summarize why you might want to
use xray you might ask yourself
so for me personally the most important
thing is that it has explicit dimensions
metadata
so in my opinion that mean that re leads
to
more readable and safer code and
it also gives you a very convenient
handle
on all the broadcasting magic and more
complicated function application
and the great thing is that it simply
generalizes tried and trusted numpy and
pandas api and desk api and beyond
so it's not some just a new kid on the
block it actually uses some
things that have some proven
technologies and yet it's a very
versatile and quite
universal thing in terms of all the data
structures which means that it kind of
leads to standardization
so all the extensions that i have
developed or other people have developed
i can use them in any context where i
can get the data into x-ray containers
which means i can
transfer any code that i have which is
written for
x-rays to any other field or any other
problem that i
might encounter and there's a lot of
these extensions and
and editions there's
of course a lot of them for geosciences
since this package comes from that
domain but there's even applications for
machine learning for example there's
harvest library which
is used for bison models or their
analysis
and many other domains
and it has even expired some c data c
plus plus
apis so that's it from
me thank you for your attention and i'm
looking forward to your questions and i
hope that i've
at least given you some reason to think
that x-ray is indeed more
than just pandas in multiple dimensions
thank you
thank you very much andre so
there are four questions on slido so
let's go really quickly through them
because it's
getting late so uh first
of them is do you know how much the
performance overhead
is compared to pure numpy but it is
significant when compared to pure numpy
of course there is some overhead because
you are working with some python objects
though since a few versions ago they
have defined slots for these
objects so it doesn't actually occupy
that much
that much dynamic memory anymore and
it's a bit faster
but yes there are some overheads so
definitely uh it
does make sense if your data is at least
i don't know
a few 100 megabytes or so if you want to
really be faster i mean it's not
actually about speed it's all about
convenience of usage
which in terms of development can turn
out to be
even more important so it's not really
about speed it's about how convenient it
is to use and how much time you'll spend
on developing
and working with uh all the functions
thank you uh so second question
uh was about executing the cells in the
slide
someone is asking how you do it i mean
just
directing the presentation right so
is this essentially just a jupyter
notebook and it will be
it's available on a small repository and
i just used something called the rise
extension for jupiter notebook which
essentially just activates the
reveal.js slides for the notebook
while the notebook is live and also i
use the split cell extension which makes
it possible to have these cells side by
side
and i had to add some uh css overrides
so that
the html output would display correctly
so that's how okay another question
uh would you comment on x-ray
compatibility
with scikit-learn and seiden
if you know something so in terms of
scikit-learn uh
there i know that there are already some
uh
libraries which do provide some
interface
and in essentially you can easily
uh ch you can easily move from a data
array to
uh to uh pandas
so you can easily create you can easily
convert it back to data frame if you if
you have something that wants to eat a
data frame
so it's not easy it's not that hard to
use and in terms of cython
uh i don't think there's any direct
compatibility
but it's pure python and it does use
slots so it should be
pretty easy to use in in cython since
it's
just using numpad if you use mostly
things that are supported by
by cython as in numpy and
pandas then it should work okay and the
last question
is uh about the uh attribute
chords uh which is the coordinates
whether it can be something
else than just the pandas index such
such as a
in quotes duck index
uh i don't i don't think so that they
i don't think they have not done much
work on supporting that
i guess it kind of might work because
they
do uh base most of their usage on
on duck typing most things so it might
work but i don't think that's something
they
are planning on supporting directly